if your wife does not look good in a
dress do you tell her if your wife
doesn't look good in a dress you need to
tell her yeah let me tell you why when
your wife is a bag of wrinkles or she's
fat while pregnant and you look over at
her and say you look so beautiful I have
never been more attracted to you in this
moment knowing that you're caring my
child she'll believe you because the
time that she looked bad in that dress
you were like you don't look good in
that dress and that is literally what I
tell my wife when she asks me something
hard and I tell her the truth I'm like I
need you to believe me when you're 80
and you're a bag of wrinkles and still I
look at you and I say you are beautiful
I am still attracted to you I'm still
into you that you know it's the truth
because in moments like this where it
would have been so much easier to lie I
didn't when I needed it to count you
knew